[Music]
uh
yeah so thanks everyone for joining um i
hope this is going to be an interesting
session
i'll i'll do my best at least so uh
what i'm gonna speak about is building a
medical device
with r uh but before i sort of go into
what a medical device is
um i wanna briefly explain what what we
actually do
so um i work at a company called inside
rx
and we um we we um
uh built a medical device as you would
have
guessed but um to go into what uh that
actually
what we are actually building um let's
say and let's hope
it it won't happen but let's say you
have to go into the hospital for uh
maybe an as an infection or something um
you will get a uh a dose of a drug
but you have to realize that those is
often
developed based on a sort of
average of a
population and it might not actually be
the best choice for you as an individual
because
you might be sort of on the on on one of
the extremes of the of the
of of that in terms of the
pharmacology now this is especially
important for drugs like antibiotics
chemotherapy and transplantation drugs
and especially if you're very young if
you're very old
or if you're very sick this is this is
actually
very important to get the right dose for
you as an individual
now um if if we have some
information about you let's say you have
the weight the height
the age of you and we know uh
all the the let's say the the the
the history of of all the drugs that you
took
we um we measured the concentration of
drug
in your body and perhaps some other
biomarkers and maybe we even have some
genomic data from you uh we can actually
uh
that that can actually help uh to inform
you
um uh about um what
what you should actually receive in in
in terms of a
drug dose and we use that data to uh to
update
our models the pharmacology models um
that we use
and we use
[Music]
bayesian updating to to actually get to
what would be the optimal um
choice for for you as an individual now
we
uh wrapped this framework um
we we built a cloud-based web
application around this framework
based again on those pharmacology models
so uh so it's not like a machine
learning black box that we don't know
what's what's going on this is uh yeah
this is all grounded in pharmacology
and the last thing i want to highlight
here is that it's integrated into the
clinical workflow so
uh the intended users here are um
it's it's it will mostly be pharmacists
but also uh we have a few uh
doctors that are they're using the
platform
now to get back to the medical device
part uh what is a medical device
well we all know that um this this
and this is a medical device i guess but
in this talk i'm gonna focus on
what is
software as a medical device and
more specifically i'm going to talk
about clinical decision support
tools um if you decide to make him
uh to build a medical device um most
likely you will go to
the following stages uh where in the the
pre-development stage
you basically decide which uh which
class of medical device you're going to
be
what are the claims you you are making
and this is also the stage where you set
up a a quality system
and then in the next stage you'll begin
development of your products
under design controls under the quality
system that you that you developed
then in later stages you'll apply um
the verification framework that you set
up
and then uh before you file with the fda
you do some of
validation uh with with actual users
uh and then you're you should be good to
to releases uh
into the world um the important
uh i i would say the most important
thing in this whole process is probably
uh the the
risk analysis that you will do uh you'll
do that
really early on and uh
in basically you scope out what what are
all the risks associated with with the
medical device and once you have that
you can actually develop
a document called
software specifications and that uh that
is just a long list of
things like the software shall
be able to do this uh and that uh
yeah basically a hundred times or more
so
uh all these requirements uh what you
can do to do then is map these two
actual
uh verification steps so
what that what that means in practice
you actually write out a specific
um requirement as a
s s s scenario
in in code uh and then um you'll
basically run through all these uh
verification steps um so
if if you speak about the the web app as
a whole what you usually use for that is
a
for example a tool like uh
uh but in the context of um uh
the the conference here i'm gonna speak
mostly about the api because
that's that's the part uh what's what's
written in r
and for that uh mainly for the unit test
we use
test that as i'm sure a lot of you
are also using but i want to focus on uh
one other thing here is that
what we developed in-house which is a
package called
json2
test and what what that package
specifically is doing is
um oh i also want to refer here to the
talk yesterday by uh alice huge
which was a very interesting talk
more or less about the same thing here
but going into the
package what we developed what the
package does
is because if you remember all the
requirements that we had to
um to write down and to write out as as
code
instead of writing these all out as code
as a specific
scenario to walk through we actually uh
record the the api payloads that
are being
sent from the web app and then write
a document that basically specifies what
we expected api
load to be and then we compare it with
the actual api
output so um instead of writing all
these tests
uh we use a package to actually do it
for us
so that has helped us to uh to implement
this uh
a lot faster than we would otherwise
have been able to do so this this this
package is also available um
uh uh in in this link uh it's not yet on
cram
so that's more or less what i want to
say about
some of the uh the validation
the verification steps that are required
but i also want to um go into more about
what is required
um what what other things are required
so um
yeah um what you also find in the in the
regulatory documents is
a lot of stuff about security privacy
stability and things like that
but once you've got speaking to clients
there will also be other
requirements of course clients also have
a lot of requirements
um about security and privacy etc but
they also
um want you to have a
like a a a a nice product
uh a good ui ux uh it has to be fast
so um the uh like i said the the
end user of our products are clinicians
they um they
they they won't have the time to wait
for half an hour for for those advice so
it has to be there
uh very quickly um so then we can go
into
uh some of the choices that we made
and uh what we developed and the first
thing here is the the computations and
like i said in introduction we use
pharmacology models
and those are often defined as
differential equations
and when we started out five years ago
there was not really
a package uh or or
anything in our to actually handle that
so that's
why we wrote a package called pkpd sim
um
and the the main thing that it's doing
it's just um
doing a uh it can do a prediction
of the the concentration of a specific
drug uh
in in the body over time and that's uh
that's basically the core of our of our
platform uh again this this this
is also uh open source uh it's open
source available
and uh the um the the
sort of the
lesson that we learned here over time is
what that
well at first it took a long um a lot of
work to
um to actually implement this ourselves
but uh over time we realized that that
is actually has been very
very good for us because that that
really helps uh helped us in
uh the regulatory process because we
know the ins and outs of this package we
know
the weaknesses and the strengths so um
it's yeah
if the fda ever comes to a door and
asks us questions about
this this package uh it will be very
easy for us to to
to provide them with answers another
thing that this package does is
because we have to support uh not just
one one model
but we support over 100 pharmacology
models
the the pkpd sim package can actually
generate new
packages uh based on uh specifications
that you provide
so you write a spec file um where you uh
describe the drug and you describe the
equations for that
for that specific model that will be
then put into
a package example
and then that will be compiled validated
and
deployed and the benefits of this is
that it
makes it a lot easier and faster to
develop these models and and also to
maintain it
and also to um create the
the end user documentation for all these
models because that's
also something that we have to provide
to to the clinician or to the pharmacist
so then a little bit uh about the
architecture well
we're speaking about speaking at an um
an
our uh
conference and we're speaking about uh
web applications so
um that the the elephant in the room
that we have to address is uh shiny um
and of course
uh uh i think it's it's it's it's um
it's it's it's it's it's it's fine to um
to to write uh a medical device in
shiny that's uh there's absolutely
absolutely no objection to that um
there's if you if you and if you're
worried about uh sort of the
um the scalability of that you can
always split off the
the api uh so that it skills
independent independently from the from
the web application
uh so that's completely fine but um
really early on we made the decision to
not go with shiny
and that was mostly because uh we
thought in the end it would be the
application would be um uh too
complex that would be too hard to to
develop in shiny that's why we
went with a sort of more uh
default uh javascript stack
if we then go into the api itself which
we of course left in in
in r um we need to to
um what you have to keep in mind is is
uh the scale and then the
load requirements for the api well we
don't have the um
uh the load requirements that were that
were uh
presented before like a million uh users
a day
or a million api calls a day we have a
little bit less we have now um
i mean we are growing but we have we
have uh about a few hundred api calls an
hour
um but you you do have to keep in mind
that um
uh it's not always the same uh
over the course of a day that we always
have a peak in
in the in the in the morning when the
the users
on the on the east coast wake up
and what you also have to keep in mind
is that the length of the api call is
not
always the same we have a lot of api
calls that are really fast
within a second but there's also api
calls that um
that actually take much longer depending
on how much
information you have for the for the
specific patient
um so that that that also leads to the
question of uh what api framework you
you're gonna use well when we started
out
uh about five years ago uh the first api
framework that
we built was was our
our own um
but we we quickly realized that um
a a great great application already
existed and that was called opencpu
which basically exposes
our
packages as as an api
and that that that that has has worked
really well for us
um and we initially put that just on the
server
in the cloud um but later we moved that
uh
uh to a um a
version so it would uh would scale more
easily up and down uh depending on the
load
and that's that has worked really well
for us um of course
at this meeting there's has been a lot
of talk already about plumber
we are looking into it it has a few um
nice things that it it can do um but
there will be something for the future
uh
we we might move to that another thing
here uh
that would be good to mention is maybe a
lambdas or on amazon
uh which basically um allows you to
upload a specific function and then uh
you you can easily uh you
use that function and you don't have to
worry about this scaling at all so
that's another option that we might look
into and i also know that there's a lot
of
other folks that are working on api
frameworks um
but i i don't have the time to go into
that so to round off
um i think um yeah the main question
medical devices are if there was a a
a question mark in in anyone's mind
i think uh uh yes it it's it's um
it's not a problem uh there's no uh
regulatory requirement that
that actually says you have to develop
your tool in a specific language
functional
testing is really important remember all
those
requirements that you have to go through
and what
really helped us i think uh to um to
actually do that to develop
that at scale is store as much in
metadata as you can uh that also really
helped us with uh
maintaining all these models uh as well
uh and then the last thing that i um uh
briefly mentioned is that uh
i in my opinion really helped us to
that we at least the crucial code uh for
our medical device that we
had to to write it ourselves so we know
exactly what's what's going on
under the hood um well thank you for
your attention
and i'd be happy to ask some questions
[Applause]
so we have a couple of questions mostly
on the clinical side
so how does this functionality
integrate into the clinical workflow and
uh
does it integrate into a ehr yeah that's
a
that's a great one um yes we do
integrate with
all the major ehr vendors like
epic and cerner
and the way it usually works is
the pharmacist or the the the doctor is
actually working on a patient
in in their main workflow and then they
can click a button
uh to get an advice from us um
and that that basically brings up um
our
web application and then uh in
in our view so all the um
the specific data that we need is
already there so uh the
user only has to look at our screen and
make a make a
d this
decision about those so they don't
actually have to enter any any
any more data thank you and um
does um
and let's see how about um
domain knowledge in the development
process or do you have pharmacists on
your team
yes uh i'm a pharmacist but i'm
also a researcher and a developer uh so
i have uh
i have more than one hat but we do now
have um
three pharmacists on staff as well um to
to help with development to
because they they actually know uh
what's important to to
actually show to the user they help a
lot out with the support as well
so so is the is a device effective
across classes of drugs like oncological
or psychotropic drugs
yeah we we have a few modules in
oncology
i would say most of our modules are in
infectious diseases because that's
that's where the most
need is but we are looking into a lot of
other classes as well yeah
so thank you so much so please thank our
[Applause]
[Music]
speakers
you